it can be really easy to see a whole
bunch of isolated stories and events and
not see them as part of a broader
societal cultural and governmental move
in any particular direction so I want to
put together just a few of the events
that have taken place in the last seven
to ten days to point out to you that we
are very quickly moving towards an
authoritarian crony capitalist corrupt
dystopia more than we already are in any
way I want to catch you up just on a few
of the stories from the last week and
think through what all of these stories
together mean just think about what in
the last week has taken place Donald
Trump's reelection campaign is now
paying legal fees for his kid out of
donor money okay Trump's reelection
campaign is paying hundreds of thousands
of dollars to Trump owned properties and
this is for the 2020 election big money
is being made by the president and his
family out of political donors money
Trump's lawyer Jay Sekulow was on all
five sunday shows yesterday total
coverage unified message same mouthpiece
for the government on every one of the
five major Sunday morning shows Trump's
own election integrity Commission is
heating up they televised a lunch late
last week talking about how they're
going to fix this non-existent problem
of in-person voter fraud all with the
goal of further infringing on voter
rights and in addition House Republicans
are looking to defund the election
assistance Commission which is the only
federal agency that exclusively works to
ensure that the voting process is secure
Trump's air war has killed more than
2,000 civilians already are you hearing
much about that not in corporate media
and meanwhile you've got the White House
railing against foreign workers and
immigrants while Trump's own businesses
you might not have heard of this are
filing for visas to bring in foreign
workers The Associated Press reported
that the Trump Organization has asked
the federal government which of course
Donald Trump is the president
- grant dozens of visas to allow foreign
nationals to come work at two of Donald
Trump's private clubs in Florida
publicly he's against undocumented
immigration he's against foreign workers
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah and he's asking
for special permits through his
businesses to bring in foreign workers
to quote take American jobs and this is
all while Trump creates made in America
week which of course relates to none of
Ivanka Trump's products being
manufactured in the United States most
of Donald Trump's apparel not being
manufactured in the United States and at
the same time Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson is set to shudder the State
Department's war-crimes Office which for
two decades was there to hold war
criminals accountable at the same time
you've got Jeff Sessions the Attorney
General as we learn more and more about
the lies he's told about his Russia
connections putting out a new directive
aimed at increasing police seizures of
cash and property and even some
Republicans are against this Rand Paul
tweeted asset forfeiture is an
unconstitutional taking of property
without trial
it's creeping authoritarianism Pat and
when you look at all these stories
separately you say not good but not a
huge scandal if you put it all together
and this was just one week we have
serious creeping authoritarianism in our
country and even just offhand I can
think of a couple more things to add to
that list which is in that New York
Times interview Donald Trump attacked
his own attorney general right and he's
also been floating this idea of firing
the special prosecutor Robert Muller
sure those are power grabs I mean you
know you appoint those people and they
are in the executive branch but they're
also quasi independent organizations
that rosid like and the idea that he can
just that they owe him something in
return that they owe him his loyalty and
instead of you know loyalty to the
American people or the Constitution
that's an authoritarian streak and the
the biggest indicator that this is all
really bad is that many of the things I
just mentioned to you might not sound
like a big deal when some years ago any
one of the events I just
mentioned all of which took place in the
last seven to ten days by the way would
be Red Alert
discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forum david pakman.com slash
our IDI di t today's sponsor is zip
recruiter if you are hiring you need to
know where to post your job to find the
best candidates and it can be tough with
zip recruiter thankfully you can post
your job to over 100 job sites with one
click and then zip recruiters technology
will efficiently match the right people
to your job and that's why the zip
recruiter system is different
unlike other job sites zip recruiter
doesn't depend on candidates finding you
it will find them and in fact over 80%
of jobs posted on zip recruiter receive
qualified candidates within the first 24
hours and with zip recruiters backend
control panel you don't need to juggle
emails you don't need to juggle calls to
your office you can screen rate and
manage candidates all in one place right
now our listeners and viewers can post
jobs on zip recruiter for free if you go
to zip recruiter dot-com forward slash
free trial that is zip recruiter com
slash free trial one more time you can
try it free at zip recruiter com slash
free trial